welcome to this video in New five minute
game if you keep a bit of track about my
writing here on five minute you see that
I lost quite a number of points this is
so because I tried a new recording
software and done while most it is
because I didn't play well but it's
related to to the some software
experiments trying to to change some
things in the videos but it turned out
to really irritate me while playing so I
lost a couple of games in a row let's
see you ok we have a um a modern below
me here and quite interesting with the
quick h 5h for pushing my night back to
f1 but ok in the meantime black has
played a quite a number of moves that
are yeah well it's not clear if they're
always useful how to play an interesting
i can go Knight d2 also yeah probably i
should do that the night on everyone is
not especially well placed well if you
ask me why it is substantially better
but i'm probably probably would access
almost any benoni position in that way
because i really don't understand what
black is doing with with this night on h
5 and so on ok Knight to e5 guy can I
can just take it and now I'm ready for F
for you can never castle because of
Bishop take it takes h5 I mean NEVER
Cassilis may be a bit strong but I don't
really see him at
it happening in this game in the in the
nearest future I think I'm also
threatening Bishop g5 phone really and
now your queen okay i can make any way
32 g 7 it's very ugly but may be
playable
if I take on h5 and play f4u needs to
play Bishop d4 probably and look do you
one yeah that's all quite ugly but
Bishop takes h5 is not yeah it's not
clear that I want to do that he might
play neither for them ok let's let's do
that it's a concrete line should be for
the question is what what am I playing
against that mm yeah maybe I can just
take it and then then get the deep on I
mean he has no way to defend it really
look do you wanna this uh no Bishop g4 i
can i can simply i can take on d4 ed
queen d 4 but then the screen f4 now
this is far too complicated and
unnecessary okay yeah well i can go if
I've but the question is take stakes and
fall and if I hang some
yeah that's far from convincing I mean
I'm not not in a bit not in bad shape
but I really should have gotten more out
of this position I have to better porn
structure at least yeah I'm not sure
maybe I think you should take I mean
otherwise out yeah okay that one that's
that's a possibility mm-hm this Bishop
is of course potentially better than my
night but not sure how romantic it is
i'm i still have the better structure
with to pawn islands against against
against three yeah depending how you
count even for each for you could count
as one eyelid if you like okay check
look III h three guys got Luca very
simple very simple chess but effective
noise got g5 yeah I'm simply miss
playing this giving him giving him all
kinds of activity ah what a game yeah
I'd always feels bad to lose against
such yeah strange opening play with age
five and age four and weakening
everything but simply fair to punish it
now everything's very much okay
yeah I had no way to protect protect you
protect bones so yeah now i'm at least
Im I've got some slide to slide activity
check you can just take take on a form
I'm not quite sure why you check why it
doesn't do that so somewhat somewhat
strange
yeah non-threatening Knight b6 and
Knight f6 check you can give the check
on h8 of course check yeah it's some
activity but not enough really yeah this
is completely unnecessary Jack giving up
the bishop okay you could have simply
retreated the bishop
one problem is it's still not not clear
at all I mean his bonds are dangerous
try to get the King to help but it's
it's tricky yeah III and so on time
morning check
okay one now and some
it's not much I can do really the pants
are very very dangerous
you can just play B 3 n's win I think
check yeah it's really frustrating but
this guy's playing and probably still
King knocking a three-night be one is
got rock be two check check check check
game drive know it no at the end I'm
drawing yeah this was really a crap game
from both sides what can you do need to
be honest we need to be honest with you
I played it really badly but he didn't
really yeah it should be 00 this game
yeah how did the opening I cannot
believe this at all i think black
assassin simply terrible here you cannot
you cannot castle and what what kind of
position is this the computer is as
usual very ruthless wants to play g4 and
claims white is already winning let's
let's have a look at that this didn't
cross my mind at all I'll just play this
in all the looking move g4 is an
interesting one though this is his idea
or its idea attending maybe you've g4
pushing yeah opening up the position
it's not bad why does far better
coordinated okay but this is not bad
let's um let's have a look maybe night
c4 is not really good because it helps
them to exchange some pieces maybe just
castles I mean what's what is Plex move
now I mean if this is this is unplayable
I don't I don't really see what black is
doing now cannot play b5 he cannot place
you for the compounds to play wiki stuff
like queen is having and then Bishop
deform I mean okay now this is probably
less convincing
yeah this is not this is really not
helping I guess Jim lon castle and
sister much better
yeah this is in fact quite comfortable
white can block the prominent erm yeah
this is okay it's not nothing special
but it's okay the way it was played I
was I was worse even he I'm worse and I
need to be really precise which I wasn't
here it's okay but now I know I'm
playing real nonsense need to be I'd
need to look III was especially bad i
mean i can give this check it's not
really helping button here i need to
need to do something else is just
terrible running into into this attack
and g5 I know black is probably close to
winning even check check Gannon it was
it was hard to understand jack why now
took on h2 you can simply you can simply
keep keep your pawn look g8 or whatever
just OB ships is six I don't really see
what what's wrong with that okay maybe
the h points cat impossible but still he
gave me either the bishop and here yeah
I had this facility but after that it's
not clear where the night is going I can
go here yeah maybe this is a way to draw
actually like this check possible the
auntie em I'm probably worse with the
three pawns camp maybe this rook h2ax
store was okay i mean it's it's possible
however you can easily win around here
just anything else besides what what he
did I mean this is just just giving it
away and he's got plenty of time King
before something like that just not ran
into cactus not run into this
this is a chant trick of course all
rights it's even that is the drone even
that is the drawn this is quite quite
funny chandi check very very handy way
to draw alright thanks for watching